combien vous êtes de 5 10 10 sacs vont
reculer la bouchard je vous descendez
pas ce samedi matin la croix rouge vient
de récupérer un don inné 10 150 kg de
pommes de terre directement du
producteur
cinq associations du territoire ont pu
récupérer des denrées
c'est bien ça va nous aller pour la
semaine se voit pas trop les garder
longtemps et puis ça va ça va être bien
pour distribuer gratuitement la semaine
prochaine une fois par semaine ya des
distributions alimentaires et donc ça
aidera à améliorer le colis des pommes
de terre parce que des produits frais
c'est pas toujours évident d'en avoir
après la verrière et rappelé les
agriculteurs installés dans le nord de
la france ont fait une halte à elancourt
un geste de solidarité déjà c'est
important c'est pas normal en tant que
producteur qu'on doive jeter de la
marchandise
les associations s'ils voulaient elles
sont vraiment elles ont beaucoup plus de
personnes qu'avant la actuellement il ya
environ alors les restos du coeur vient
de me dire justement qu'ils ont 40% de
plus de personnes en situation de
précarité que l'antre l'an dernier on
essaie vraiment de travailler en lien
avec toutes ces associations
on travaille vraiment partenariat et
puis on lit soutien sur le plan
logistique
les associations ont récupéré entre 100
et 500 kg chacune 22 tonnes ont été
proposés à la vente